so they had an easy question upon which
I would call if it looks like this
problem it smells like a problem we
haven't really talked about this in
explicit terms but one of the things
that makes projectile motion a little
tricky is that you're dealing with not
one not two but three variables think
about it in fact I've got them all the
board right now he doesn't have any
explicitly separately
you have a horizontal component to your
mission so I'm gonna put women put
velocity under second so I'm gonna say
yes
dots by the way I hope you've gotten
used to making your dots because you
really can't avoid it
in emotion you play the player
are you really used to making your
thoughts really big and fat and not just
don't just do that because especially
we've done it hard in terms of curing
example you don't want to be the person
few mysteries there X dot is X or
example DUP so we're going to X compare
me of a horizontal herds this motion we
also have a vertical component to this
motion and we've got that we've had to
change is because you remember what
where you first have a look at simple
harmonic motion and all of the
straight-line motion actually we had to
sort of get used to saying that the
vertical axis on our graph was whatever
the displacement it was it maybe that's
right it made it run down whatever but X
is the only kind is basically where on
the vertical axis but now we might
really go into work we have two
dimensions of motion so we have X and we
have Y but we have a third variable
namely what's the other network time
right now we've been used to putting
time into these different equations and
then getting results out of them like
where are you what about you know maybe
you got another car might be objects
from everything what are what you know
is the time it's a third variable and
effects you Algerian it's a very one two
three that's what others you know now we
have a
we have whole topic orders we call this
a parameter it's a third variable and
effects to others who have a right so
for example on the on the unit circle we
can think of it in terms of X's and Y's
but we can also keep them in terms of
the angles subtended at the center
between the positive x-axis and the
radius that should whatever point you're
at right so this theta this is variable
affects your X Y or Y in terms of or you
can call them cos theta and sine theta
right now one of the big things it's a
lot of time and effort in the topic of
parametric coming up with parametric
equations right and x equals this and
why it was that like this and then we
would eliminate the parameter but
sometimes it's really useful to do that
and we're going to do exactly the same
thing here instead of having six
equations X my donor and star Y naught x
and y we're going to boil everything
down to just one equation that talks
about the palm of our projector and
because it is just a single equation we
call it originally the equation apart
okay now it's so much simpler it has
their times in it so that's kind of you
know disadvantage if you want to know
where things are happening the equation
apart it's not going to help you very
much but I was in you don't care about
when many of them figure out the
questions we've been asking you so far
we ask things like where do you get
packed with the wall or when it rebounds
off that other than advertising board or
somewhere that where does it land okay
we very frequently ask where questions
and all you need for where is X's and
Y's that's you don't need when
necessarily okay so what we are going to
do what we're going to say is to create
the equation apart we're going to try to
eliminate the criminal okay that's our
goal we're trying to a good time so to
do that we're gonna do it right from the
beginning right from like base
principles because I contemplated just
giving you the equations and then we
and eliminate the parameter fairly
easily but yes there is life mrs. Lee's
and I were coming around to all of you
it's even like this was a theme that you
struggle with so I'm going to relay the
baby down so that it sort of traits a
little bit so at time zero okay I want
to leave out what we normally know I'm
about a projectile vision situation we
normally get given how fast it's going
so let's call them the initial speed and
then we also get given an angle of
projection right so you've got like so
by the way we call it alpha run in the
theatre because it's your angle of
projection this is where you begin right
so an alphabet that's what is okay now
we'll come to next art and why not in a
second but what I want you to remember
is that project operation always starts
with two differential equations right
two equations that tell you what are the
forces acting on this situation what's
what's changing your boss in therefore
your displacement okay excuse me we're
going to have a horizontal force acting
as you say of course it isn't acting and
we're also going to have a clinical work
so we're going to do this for base
principles okay so when you think about
projectile motion what is the horizontal
force that's acting on this object as it
flies through the air
once it's flying is a speeding up or
slowing down when we talk about
horizontal the answer is it's - speeding
up or slowing down it just kind of gets
projected it's not propelled is there a
pocket on the back of it it's very
parachute slowing it down it just gets
thrown right so there is no horizontal
force acting on it right and the same
way there is a single force you have to
worry about when it comes to the
vertical component what's acting on this
one what's premium back down to the
ground of making Jeannette pop dragon
it's just grabbing right so since it's
grabbing its pull you down to the ground
we put a minus sign is negative right
and then we say Jean in this case
because I haven't told you what around
the years I've had said
ten days into it or nine point eight
billion spin it
it's kind of future fusion between those
two if you don't get told anything just
has to say to you for grabbing now just
like you have to rally together just
like in simple harmonic motion where you
always start off with this but this is
the differential equation that describes
everything and just like in exponential
growth decay where you don't try to see
that where we always start with yes
right this is kind of like this is the
differential equation that defines
everything okay this here this is the
seventh differential equations that
define everything when it comes to
projectile motion
so this has to be your smiley one okay
so now we have to climb up the ladder
right we've got that first two equations
and now we need to get and thanks to
from acceleration we're going to go to
velocity so here when we integrate once
you've got zero so when you need to in
zero-g and obviously the end up in the
confident now you'll notice as we go
through this I'm gonna have to create 40
equations all of them are my
intervention so I have counted one two
three four word integrations to do so
there if I'm not just gonna say it's a
concert I'm gonna say it's a particular
constant cuz I gotta have a few more
flavor okay now it already find out what
this constant is I'm gonna have to go
back to our diagram over here before
right I need an initial condition or
some kind so what we're gonna have a
look at the initial
only via break what are each of these
things equal should we're going to use
trigonometry here right you're a right
angle so what's this horizontal leg
thank you what ratio we're gonna use the
connect this to that think is alpha
between X is adjacent right so this is
going to be V cos alpha because cos
alpha will be X dot on base so I just
multiplied to you by date does that make
sense in the same way and obviously you
might as well do it one way to locate
this radical triangle what will why
don't be able to be sine theta and is it
know some sorry how far I should say
it's a nice parallel here between this
diagram and again sir
because you've got cause adidas I clean
up on the unit circle
that's horizontal then go right it goes
in order and it's the same do here
cosines RF horizontals signs are out
okay all right so I have my initial
conditions so I'm going to say initially
I've got X dot equals imposes alpha and
I'm also going to say because I'm going
to use it in the next intervention as
well next couple more populous I'm also
going to state this additional condition
because I've used it over here and why
don't ya I enjoy going ahead and putting
this in another color and highlighting
it like this because of what employers
have gotten confused about why not
why there is a function of time right it
changes over time as opposed the next on
excellent is always equal to this
because there's no force acting on it
that's nothing to you but why do you
sort of come to this and then you try to
substitute that into equations but it's
not something to substitute in right
it's sorry you try to substitute into
this but it's not it's just any
particular time it's not that [ __ ]
you're interested okay so once you do
this you can work out this first
consonant what's it going to be it's
just going to beat yourself up right
so that's great and this allows me to do
one more integration to finish off my
exercise notice I keep everything very
yeah right I get to great one more time
over here and I guess what happens is
this it gets a T on it because I'm
integrating with respect to time we
tensor at the T in here to the capital
so that we don't confuse the TV inside
the cosine place that's the reason why
it's in the middle and of course because
you integrated in an indefinite way
again you get okay now what we're doing
is we're just considering like the most
basic kind of projectile motion so where
would you think that we would start we
over the
obey the origin so I'm going to put 0 0
you can take that initial condition
right I'm going to do using him
initially 0 I'm going to use this for
the excellent website and from this you
work out that your constant heat or
displacement is just going to be in this
case it's just zero right because when
you put 0 into here for time if you get
0 over here your initiative this
placement is something wet to just have
C 2 so X is just going to be this tada
okay now we come back to this in a
second because we want to eliminate T on
this right I've got a paramedic we don't
want ever to break it I want a Cartesian
one so we're going to return to this
equation in a minute